Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Glad to have you here today.
Today we are transitioning to turn our gaze
from the problem that we have within our heart
to look at how God cures and solves that problem.
Now, today, I want to tell you that the theme is this, that
holiness is gifted to us at the new birth.
Holiness is gifted to us at the new birth.
There's three ways in which sin has broken humanity, and
really more, but there are three main ones that I'm dealing with today
specifically. The first one is that legally we are
guilty. So one of the problems we have before God in our unsaved
state is that we are legally guilty of a list of offenses
against God. All right? So God deals with that in what
we call justification. Justification by faith.
So God says... I drew a little picture here of a, love my artwork,
of a judge's gavel. So the gavel comes down and God says, "I
declare you not guilty. I remove your sin from
you, and I place the righteousness of Christ upon you.
I declare you not guilty." And so God deals with our
legal guilt against Him in that way.
Another way is that we are separated relationally from God.
The Bible says we're strangers and aliens.
Jesus says we're even, in John 8:44, "children of the devil."
All right, so
that is pretty significant, right?
We're clearly in the wrong family relationally.
In our terms of our relationship with the Lord, we are separated from Him,
and God deals with that by adoption, by bringing us
near, and not only bringing us near so that we're part of His...
But by making us part of His family.
So He adopts us into
His family. So my little stick figure family there.
Now,
the third problem is that spiritually we are unholy and we
are dead. There is no life flowing from the source of
holiness, from the source of all life flowing into us.
And this is a problem because Hebrews 12:14 says,
"Without holiness, no man will see the Lord." So
the stakes are pretty high there, right?
It's clearly a significant issue if we
are unholy and dead in trespasses and sins.
And God deals with that reality, He deals with it
by giving us... I'm going to draw a little symbol of wind here.
Let's see. I don't know, that's probably not a very good symbol of wind.
But the wind of the Holy Spirit, the breath of God, just as God
breathed into Adam and Eve
new life at the beginning, the Holy Spirit breathes into us and
blows into us with a regenerating,
a regeneration power, and this
regeneration produces a new life.
So we have a life, a new and
holy life. And so this is the holiness,
the holy, pure life, the flowing of God's power
and life into us, formerly dead and lost.
This regeneration is the holiness that God gifts to
us. So there's justification, there's adoption, and there's regeneration.
A brand-new, holy, pure life gifted to
us by God. Specifically in Hebrews 13,
after this, "No one will see the Lord without holiness," in
Hebrews 13, the scripture tells us that
Jesus suffered outside the gate that He might make the
people holy. And so how is it that we can go
from lost and broken and sinful
and wicked to the place where we are,
where the most common word in the scriptures,
for a Christian is hagioi?
How do we go to that place where we are hagioi?
I'm sorry, hagioi, I didn't define that.
In Greek, that means holy ones, literally the holy
ones. It's translated saints frequently. It's the most common word.
So how do we go from this place of
no
rightness with the Lord and far from Him to
holiness? Well, God gifts us a new and holy
life. We were dead, and yet now we
are alive, and we have a brand-new holy life gifted
to us in the new birth.
So the reason I want to bring this out is
because God makes it possible for us to meet in a
moment of time at the new birth, makes it possible for us to have the
holiness without which no one will see the Lord.
But if you remember, holiness is not a
static gift. It's not a static thing.
It is a life dynamic, moving, flowing
sort of thing. We talked about that in that God's presence
makes something holy, and when it is broken, the connection is broken, it's not
holy any longer. And so not in the same
sense that it was before. So the
regenerative life that God gives us in a moment of time at the new birth
is a moving, flowing, adapting, growing,
changing sort of thing. So we are gifted this
holiness, but the holiness that we are gifted
has a will. Okay? We are given a
holiness by God, by His presence in us and within us
through Romans 8:9. The Holy Spirit comes to live within us.
We are gifted the holiness of God by the presence of the
regenerating power of the Spirit within us.
And yet that holiness we've been gifted has a will.
It has a will for your life. It has a will for your
direction.
And to maintain and be with that holiness,
we must move with it because it is moving, it
is progressing, it is pushing forward, it is drawing us, and it is changing
and transforming us on an ongoing basis.
We must move with it. So holiness is gifted to us in new birth, which
is why God is able to call all people saints.
He's able to call all Christians, all those believers in Christ, saints as the most
common word for us in the New Testament.
So you are Saint So-and-So. I'm
Saint Darryl. It's nice to meet you. All right?
So I think this is a crucial thing for you to understand because in a moment
of time, God gifts it to us, but the holiness that he gifts us
through the presence of the Holy Spirit in our lives, it's as if the water
bottle that had the vacuum in it, as if the lid
was taken off, and suddenly now
there is a presence of the Holy Spirit within us.
There is a real presence of the wind of the Spirit
in our lives.
And this is full of air right now. It is.
I've released the vacuum, and air rushed into the empty space,
and now it is full of air. It has the
wind of the Spirit, if you will,
moving into it and is full of that. So
we're going to talk more about what this means going forward and how
God fills us then with the Holy Spirit later.
But I just wanted to bring that out and say that in a moment of time, God
gifts it to you. So I think that today, as you do your
workbook and as you pray, that you should just be grateful and
thankful for the gift of holiness that God gives us.
And then turn your mind and your heart toward the fact that that holiness, that
life force of holiness, regenerative power of the Holy Spirit within
you, has a will for your ongoing holiness to take
you deeper into new levels, which is what we're going to talk about
tomorrow. Thank you for being here today. See you tomorrow.